hey youtubers it's Charlie so we've been
talking a whole bunch about Captain
America and spider-man just because all
the Marvel stuff has been going on Tom
Holland is the new Peter Parker so I
figured it was time to start talking
about spider-man villains Kevin Feige
actually said this really funny thing he
said you know everyone just kind of
takes for granted that he's in Captain
America Civil War but they said that
they're still trying to settle on a
villain for that first new spider-man
movie at Sony the biggest problem that
they have is that they have too many
choices there are like too many good
spider-man villains that's actually part
of the true value of the spider-man
character just in terms of IP at a movie
studio they have a whole new creative
team behind it they want to do something
new so that they can't just do
spider-man villains that we've seen
before or if they are gonna do that they
need to do them in dramatically
different ways the way they're talking
about it what was probably gonna happen
is is we won't see like a specific
spider-man villain till that first
spider-man movie like they're just not
gonna worry about it during Captain
America Civil War look there's already
way too many characters in that movie
most of the energy right now is focused
on finishing that movie so don't expect
any like huge spider-man announcements
and in terms of villains at least till
the end of the year till after they've
dropped the first Captain America civil
war trailer just to put it into context
the timeline of the new spider-man
movies will sync up with the Marvel
movies spider-man and his new movies
will be part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but they're not gonna try and
gum up the works by turning the
spider-man franchise into an Avengers
franchise based on what Kevin Feige is
saying about it right now I'm just
assuming we're gonna see cameos from
Avengers in the spider-man movies but
for the most part they're gonna exist on
their own think of the way guardians of
the galaxy fits into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
you know we didn't see like a ton of
earth-based Avengers stuff in that movie
and we're probably gonna see it in the
second movie either but they are all
connected so expect spider-man to
connect in the same way that guardians
connects with the other Marvel movies so
just working down the list here are like
my top 5 favorite spider-man villains
some of them also crossover with other
Marvel characters so you see how this is
a really good thing that they form this
agreement with Sony starting with number
5 kingpin very awesome daredevil villain
probably gonna stay mostly in that
universe but now that we have Spider Man
we can use the Daily Bugle we can do
more Hell's Kitchen we can we can open
it up to the rest of New York pretty
much
he's definitely classic and he's a great
character all by himself Vincent
D'Onofrio
doing a great job of developing that
character you see in season two it'll
get even crazier but one of the things I
think that's going to prevent him from
being in that first spider-man movie is
that he's such a high school character
Peter Parker will be around 16 when we
see him so Wilson Fisk is a more mature
villain so I think if he plays any kind
of role in this new spider-man trilogy
it'll it'll be background at most like
he'll be a villain to one of the other
villains typically what you want for the
very first spider-man villain of a new
trilogy is someone who's very personal
Peter Parker has to have a very deep
relationship with whoever they pick and
right now kingpins deepest enemy
relationship is with daredevil he's
trying to take over the city and that's
not something that a high school kid
would be worried about he'd be like okay
I'm gonna let the Avengers take care of
this because I'm worried about passing
my math test on Friday interestingly
enough he's one of the few spider-man
villains to gain spider-man powers it
was back during 2011 when did did Spider
Island storyline that was kind of like a
shark jump moment for me so it was just
like a little too ridiculous
another had that spider verse now and I
loved spider-gwen silk is very
interesting but it's like you just you
can't give everybody spider-man powers
without it getting ridiculous there were
actually a lot of theories that Marvel
was doing that as a way to subtly shade
Sony with their spider-man franchise I
don't think that's true I think they
were just trying to do something
different with the characters but I
always loved hearing about tin foil
marvel theories on it's number 4 Kraven
the hunter I think Sony had actually
planned to use him in their sinister six
spin-off movie which isn't is now kind
of dead in the water I know everyone
always asks about that what happened to
venom and sinister six they'll get made
eventually but not before this new
spider-man trilogy prettiman is just
like old school sinister six so of
course he's got to be on the list
sinister six as a group could almost be
treated as one villain just because
there's so much fun together it's like
the flash rogues very interesting by
themselves but way more interesting when
they get together it was this really
crazy storyline that I don't think that
they would ever do on screen but it's
just so amazing it's called Cravens last
hunt it is from like way way back in
1987 Kraven hunts down spider-man puts
him in a coma buries him in the ground
makes a copy of his costume and in his
mind goes around fighting crime like
spider-man just to prove that he's
better at spider-man than everything
even at
job that to me just sounds like the most
comic-book ease story ever it's just
like a story that would never work in
any other format like Howard the Duck
Deadpool level ridiculousness to be fair
the wisecracking spider-man is a little
ridiculous himself so you can do sillier
things when you're doing a spider-man
story it's just that certain Marvel
characters take themselves more
seriously than others like daredevil
gritty crime drama not super ridiculous
spider-man also a bit of a crime drama
but just a little bit more fun because
it's a story about a high schooler he
wisecracks a lot so you can think of it
as like the midpoint between say like
daredevil and a Deadpool story whereas
like Deadpool is like way over the top
on to number three Mysterio and not just
any Mysterio because there's been a
bunch of him the original Quentin Beck
interestingly enough also a daredevil
villain so you see how all this
spider-man stuff just worked so much
better now that he's part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe this version the
Mysterio was the one that started out as
the special-effects wizard when he was
in the process of forming his identity
for the first time you know becoming
Mysterio for the first time he actually
targeted spider-man because he wanted to
get better he wanted to be a super
villain but he wanted to pick a
relatively inexperienced superhero to go
up against I don't know that Marvel and
Sony would choose someone this weird to
go with for their first villain but he
totally works with high school
spider-man with the Tom Holland
spider-man he will be super
inexperienced this whole new trilogy
will probably end with him graduating
high school so it's like a big education
process for on this whole time on to
number two venom you could almost say
the real villain is the symbiote and
they've done just as many weird things
with the symbiote and it's like
spreading the character across a bunch
of different incarnations is they have
with spider-man himself
look you have anti-venom you have the
Flash Thompson venom who's in space with
guardians of the galaxy and it's kind of
like a really dark hero
you have carnage who they actually did
something really interesting with during
the axis storyline you can see why they
wouldn't want to do like a venom
spin-off movie there's just so many
directions you go with that character
and and we can just forget about
spider-man 3's venom just put that out
of your mind we'll just put that in a
drawer somewhere and never go look for
it
the reason venom is such a compelling
story is is because he's almost like
this dark mirror of spider-man is that
the dark place and his sould that he
doesn't want to look at
that's the whole symbiotes story you
just he gets so dark and he's like oh my
god what's happened to me I need to get
rid of this that's why I don't think
we're gonna see him anytime soon and in
the new spider-man trilogy or if we do
it won't be till the very end because
before this Tom Hollands spider-man has
a dark identity that he has to grapple
with he has to have an identity to begin
with so I'll have to spend all of his
time in Captain America Civil War in
this first movie just establishing what
baseline is before he can go dark just
in the way that Punisher is gonna be the
lethal version of daredevil in daredevil
season 2 venom is the lethal version of
spider-man but finally my number one
pick this is actually a tie between
Doctor Octopus and Green Goblin the
Norman Osborn Green Goblin Kevin Feige
has said this really interesting thing
about spider-man 2 you know big Doctor
Octopus movie he called it one of the
greatest superhero movies ever and I
actually I feel like you know even if it
might not be the greatest superhero
movie ever it's definitely the best
spider-man movie ever not just because
of Doctor Octopus there are million
reasons why movies are good or bad at
his core though he has a lot of
similarities to spider-man he's like
symbiote spider-man that never got rid
of the symbiote that just went dark say
what you will about superior spider-man
but I just I love the idea that they put
him into spider-man's body and he tries
to be a hero
great concept that just didn't always
work and Green Goblin obviously just
goes without saying he has that deep
personal connection with spider-man that
all villains need all great villains he
created the circumstances necessary for
spider-man to get that accidental spider
bite but in doing so led to the sequence
of events that caused him to become the
Green Goblin every great villain creates
their worst enemy in vice-versa like
every great hero creates their own worst
villain
Kevin Feige has said that they're going
all the way back to the beginning with
this new spider-man character so that
it's gonna be like the truest version to
the comics that we've ever seen that
means we'll probably see kingpin
somewhere in there we'll pricee Green
Goblin like everybody from the very
beginning here's my big question for you
guys you know who's your favorite
spider-man villain and who do you think
that they're gonna pick to be the
villain of this first new spider-man
movie like I said this is still a long
ways off they're mostly focused on
Captain America Civil War right now so
there's not even gonna be shooting this
new spider-man movie til next year
that's really like one of the big
reasons why Sony is isn't worried about
comic-con this year just because it's so
far off in the distance
they just found their spider-man they
just found their director so now they
need to work on the story and then cast
all these other big characters what they
might end up doing though is using
Captain America Civil War you know
spider-man's first appearance to promote
the first spider-man movies so we're
probably gonna start hearing more about
this next spider-man movie next spring
whenever that comes out but since it's
like so far off in the distance if there
are any spider-man videos that you guys
want me to do just let me know in the
comments this weekend I'm actually gonna
start doing my Comic Con previews
because Wednesday it's it's actually
like right around the corner Wednesday
is the first preview night and then we
start rolling into like the actual stuff
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and congratulations to this
week's Marvel giveaway winner Finn you
win a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure
to private message me on my channel so I
can get your contact info I'll explain
how my Comic Con giveaways are gonna
work whenever I start posting the Comic
Con previews the first one should post
by tomorrow so just look out for that in
the meantime just in case you guys
haven't seen it Marvel released a viral
clip that connects ant-man
to Civil War and Avengers age of Ultron
you can click here for my breakdown of
that and you can click here for my
breakdown to the Batman V Superman
preview they released yesterday thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you